Opposers, I have a shocking
confession: I can't do it all.
So I always roll
with my stranger
from another manger-- Jesus.
(laughter)
He follows me wherever I go.
That's why I order
two Bloomin' Onions
when I'm eating alone
at Outback.
-MAN: Yeah!
-(whooping, scattered applause)
And like any bro who has my
back, Jesus picks up the tab.
(laughter)
I assume.
I bounce, and I don't look back.
Now, I'm a man, and therefore,
an amazing driver.
But sometimes the road of life
gets twisty and treacherous.
That's when I sit back
and let Jesus take the wheel.
(angelic voices singing)
(applause and cheering)
Thanks, J.C.
(laughter)
Conservatives know that there
are many problems on this earth
that man just cannot solve,
so we shouldn't try.
Take teen pregnancy.
Donald Trump believes
in abstinence-only sex ed.
And Donald Trump is an expert
on abstinence.
He always, always waits
until marriage,
or until his lawyer wires them
130 grand.
(laughter)
So Trump pulled the plug
on Obama's
sinfully comprehensive
teen pregnancy program,
-which only reduced
teen pregnancy. -(men booing)
But Trump wants to eliminate it.
It's how I live my life.
When my doctor told me
to reduce my cholesterol,
I did him one better
and got rid of it completely.
(laughter)
Unrelated--
my vision is blurred,
and I smell burning toast
at all times.
(laughter)
So when it comes to sex ed,
President Trump
is letting Jesus take the wheel.
WOMAN: The Trump administration
published its new
pregnancy-prevention plan
last week.
What's being said now is
the "sexual risk avoidance,"
which is just a different way
of saying "abstinence only."
We believe that abstinence-only
education is harmful.
Wrong, lady.
You know...
you know what's harmful?
A bunch of teens running around
who know more about the vagina
than I do.
(laughter)
It's humiliating!
To get funding
under Trump's new proposal,
schools are required
to use elements
from programs like SMARTool,
a faith-friendly curriculum
that promotes abstinence
by making kids afraid of sex,
a tactic they call
"fear arousal."
(laughter, groaning)
The idea is
to make teens horny--
not for sex, but for fear.
(laughter)
It's a winning
GOP campaign strategy,
and also
why some jerk keeps (bleep)
my jack-o'-lantern
every Halloween.
(laughter)
(applause)
To be clear, I'm not saying
it's wrong
to (bleep) jack-o'-lanterns.
It's a safe alternative
to actual sex.
I'm just saying, get your own.
(laughter)
Thou shalt not covet thy
neighbor's jack-o'-lantern...
Carl.
(laughter)
This is great.
Contraception has no place
in schools.
Teens can't see a condom
these days without
snorting it up their nose.
Look at this.
(men laughing)
(laughter, groaning)
-(audience groaning loudly)
-(men laughing)
(groaning, laughter)
I am 95% sure
that's not what you're supposed
to do with condoms.
(laughter)
Bottom line: the only one
who should be knocking up
teenage girls is God himself.
-(some people groaning)
-So, to prevent teen...
Jesus, guys. Do you ev...?
Mary Magdalene.
Look it up.
So to prevent teen pregnancy,
forget the birds and the bees
and let Jesus take the wheel.
-(horn honking)
-(applause and cheering)
Yes.
Drive, Jesus, drive!
Drive all the way to the swamp,
Washington, D.C.
where Donald Trump is under
attack by Deep State forces,
and Jeff Sessions
and Rod Rosenstein refuse
to take a samurai blood oath
to protect their president.
If no one on earth can defend
our president,
we must call
on divine intervention
to shield him with prayer.
Let this fiery televangelist
lead the way.
God was faithful November 9,
and he spoke to me.
He showed me the vision
of a dome covering the president
and the Executive Branch.
This assignment would be ours--
to be a strike force,
a spiritual strike force.
The POTUS shield.
Feel that charisma! Whoa!
I haven't been this moved
in church since I learned
that we're allowed
to hurl stones at people.
But what is this
POTUS shield, you ask?
Well, who are you?
Robert Mueller?
It's... a prayer-powered
force field
protecting Donald Trump
and his MAGA mission.
It's got everything--
swords, lions,
a lake of fire, for some reason.
And you and I can be part
of the POTUS shield
by purchasing a DVD set
for a $55 donation.
This is real.
And like all donations,
it's a fixed price
that you have to pay
if you want the product.
And boy, do I want that product!
Here, take my money, Jesus.
Whoo!
And my... take my prayers.
And most important,
take the wheel.
(horn blowing)
(applause, cheering)
Yeah, Opposers, it...
it is important
to put our faith in God,
but sometimes God could use
some second-guessing.
Enter Paul Ryan.
NEWSWOMAN:
House Democrats and even
some Republicans are angry
over the sudden firing
of their longtime chaplain
by Speaker Paul Ryan.
NEWSMAN: Ryan's office
complained last year
that Conroy got too political
during a tax cut debate.
NEWSWOMAN: Conroy prayed
on the House floor,
urging lawmakers to strive
for economic equality.
Yes, good for you, Paul.
As Jesus said,
"Let thy skin be the thinnest."
(laughter)
Now, Ryan says the firing
wasn't politically motivated,
but that Father Conroy
just hadn't offered
enough spiritual support
to lawmakers.
It's a great point.
Did that chaplain ever once pray
for the return
of Paul Ryan's missing spine?
-No.
-(laughter, groaning)
-He did not. No.
-(applause, cheering)
No.
And meanwhile some people
are running around
with too much spine.
Like those pesky Parkland kids.
Why aren't you praying
about that inequality?
So, Paul Ryan,
thank you for shit-canning
this man of the cloth,
and for knowing when Jesus
shouldn't take the wheel.
You hear me, JC?
You turned a few too many waters
into wine, bud.
I hate to do this,
but, Jesus, give me the keys.
Come on.
Come on, give me the keys.
Give me the keys, Jesus.
-(heavenly choir sings)
-Yes. Yes.
Uh...
A Yaris? Really?
Jesus.